I recognize that some people feel
diminished by geologic time that humans
are made insignificant by it and I can
understand that I think it helps to
start developing some depth of field in
thinking about time I had a math teacher
who was fond of saying there are many
sizes and shapes of infinity and while
geologic time is not infinite it is long
some past events like the Pleistocene
the Ice Age happened just the other day
others say the formation of Pangaea a
while ago and some the origin of life
for instance a long time back it's also
useful to adopt the Greek distinction
between Chronos raw time billions and
billions of years and Kairos which is
time within a narrative as one starts
knowing Earth's story and those vast
stretches of geologic time are filled
with narratives protagonists and plot
lines it's no longer alienating the
characters become familiar the themes
resonant once we open a few volumes in
the library of deep time we can begin to
recognize ourselves in the tales of
earlier Earthlings indeed I find the
idea of a seven or eight thousand year
old earth with a shallow short history
positively terrifying while the
enveloping presence of so many ancestors
with such a rich anthology anthology of
life stories to share is to me deeply
comforting